[Music]
everybody is Charlie this is gonna be my
venom post-credits scene video and
explaining the ending hopefully you've
had a chance to see the film careful for
spoilers if you have not because we'll
be talking about very specific stuff
we're still doing that Spiderman ps4
game giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
venom related comment on the video I'll
name a new winner at the end of this
hopefully you stayed through both
post-credits scenes I think some people
left before the second one at the end of
the credits even though it felt like
more of an add than an actual post
credits scene like Sony's reminding
everyone hey remember this other big
spider-man related movie that we're
releasing in December please buy tickets
for that but the way they set that up is
kind of curious but the first
post-credit scene is the most direct set
up for the sequel and it was pretty much
what everyone was expecting although
maybe not quite in the way that everyone
was expecting the way they set it up was
kind of funny the wig wasn't great but
all the rumors turning out to be Cletus
Kasady aka carnage in the future turned
out to be true and I think the choice of
actors great I'm not a big fan of the
wig but I think they just wanted there
to be no doubt about what they were
setting if they wanted to be very clear
about what the sequel was going to be a
lot of the comic book readers will say
wait a minute we didn't see venom or
riot make any clear spawn during the
movie so how are they gonna get to the
carnage symbiote leading up to the big
final battle they make great pains to
let you know that fire and sonic
frequencies are deadly for the symbiotes
you see riot and Carleton Drake promptly
get barbecued within the shuttle before
it explodes in an even greater flame and
then the Venom symbiote sort of turns
itself into a parachute to protect Eddie
from the fall into the water so they
really want you to think that there is
no more riot symbiote the Venom symbiote
is the only one left on planet earth
right now because all the others besides
the riot symbiote died during human
testing or during that mysterious
encounter when carlton drake fed
quote/unquote Jenny Slade's character to
the symbiote and then it died because
nobody was watching it why weren't you
watching
what was going on there was a really
weird scene but they just wanted you to
get to the point where Carlton Drake
thought that the Venom symbiote was the
only one that he had left so that's why
he started freaking out we need to get
Eddie back until the riot symbiote
literally walked around the corner and
said hey what's up dude and entered him
so by the time he's talking to Anne at
the end of the movie and you get that
funny venom revealed that he's not dead
he's talking to Eddie inside his head
and he's going to go back to being a
regular reporter that venom is the only
symbiote left on planet Earth
so while Eddie is going off to be a
reporter he says that someone from
inside the prison system contacted him
famous or infamous serial killer Cletus
Kasady wants to be interviewed and he'll
only talk to Eddie Brock because he's
relatively famous in the San Francisco
area so I suppose that's kind of
believable they don't actually get to
the interview portion of whatever it is
the Cletus Kasady wants to get out they
have some funny banter then he has the
sequal dialogue when I get out of here
there's gonna be carnage so like I said
week not so hot
but what they could do in the sequel to
get to the carnage spawn from venom is
is that he just interviews Cletus Kasady
a couple of times and one of the times
while he's at the prison the Venom
symbiote spawns and he doesn't realize
what's happening so he doesn't think
anything of it the spawn is left at the
prison finds Cletus Kasady that's how
you get to carnage it's relatively
comic-book accurate with a few minor
changes in the comics what happened is
is that Eddie had been locked up after
being taken down by spider-man fellow
inmate Cletus Kasady wasn't too far away
the Venom symbiote came to rescue Eddie
and break him out of prison while that
was happening it spawned Eddie obviously
had no idea what was going on so he
broke out and took off but because the
spawn didn't have any of the attachment
to Eddie that the Venom symbiote did it
sought another host which ended up being
Cletus Kasady so that's how carnage was
born in the comics but there were a
couple of moments that they tried to
foreshadow what their fights would be
like when he was fighting the riot
symbiote during the movie the riot
symbiote could harden itself to metal
like density it could form blades it
could form spikes that it would turn
into projectiles so those are all things
that carnage is known for doing in the
comics so they just wanted to make
audiences familiar
what that kind of a fight would feel
like except that all the carnage
symbiote wants to do is cause chaos you
have to imagine it being like Venom's
version of the Joker someone who just
wants to watch the world burn so what
they could do is they could either call
the sequel venom versus carnage venom
carnage or they could really go for it
and just call it venom maximum carnage
we'll probably hear more about that in
the next couple of months
Venom's opening weekend seems pretty
strong so the likelihood of a sequel is
still really good right now but it'll
just depend on what the next couple of
weeks looks like if we hear anything
about a greenlight I will totally do a
video about it they signed Tom Hardy to
three movies so apparently they plan on
making a trilogy no idea what that third
film would be if they're gonna do
maximum carnage for the second film but
I think they really want to get Tom
Holland in a movie so that third movie
would probably be their Spider Man
crossover but the second post-credit
scene like I said is a little more
curious in the way that they set it up
now it's basically just a scene from
spider-man into the spider verse with
miles meeting the Jake Johnson Peter
Parker that you see in all the trailers
the one from the other earth because his
Peter Parker has already died so it's
mostly Sony just reminding you that that
movies coming out but the way they set
it up is it says like right after the
venom credits in another universe as if
it's part of a greater spider verse like
they're trying to get you to wonder
whether or not they're saying that the
venom movie is part of this spider verse
that this animated movie is also part of
like wait a minute what are they doing
here so you can take it either way I
took it as more of an ad but the way
that they set it up did leave room for
them to sort of say oh you know it's all
part of the spider verse it's just
another universe some of the universes
just happened to be animated but in the
scene miles is that ultimate Peter
Parker's grave who has already died
maybe in a fight with the Green Goblin
because that's kind of what happened
with the setup for Miles Morales in the
Ultimate Comics Peter dies in a fight
with ultimate goblin Miles is a big fan
of his eventually he's inspired by his
sacrifice to become spider-man and take
the mantle himself after he gets the
spider bite so he's an ultimate Peter's
grave saying I don't think I can do this
when all of a sudden the Jake Johnson
Peter Parker comes up on him and tries
to introduce himself before
that awkward run-in where he
accidentally knocks him out and then
tries to escape from the police with him
in tow see of them crashing their way
down the street in New York City which
is probably right before they have the
scene from the trailer where mal says
wait a minute how many of us are there
where the Jake Johnson Peter Parker
explains the multiverse to him there are
many of us from many different universes
the funny thing about the spider burst
movie is that all the comedic beats seem
very well planned out like it's a much
more well written script so all the
beats landed all the people in my
audience were laughing at the
appropriate moments there were a lot of
moments during the venom movie which I
felt like had a pretty weak script where
people were laughing at moments where
you weren't intentionally supposed to
laugh and a lot of it had to do with the
back and forth between Eddie in the
Venom symbiote but I've already done my
review of the venom movie so I'll add a
link for that at the end of this I think
the biggest problem that it had was that
the script just wasn't quite ready and
they started to shoot because they
wanted to get the movie out so quickly
usually what happens in situations like
that is that they actually start
shooting the movie before the script is
done so hopefully they'll take their
time with the sequel and we'll get a
really badass venom versus carnage movie
but post all your theories and reactions
in the comments below what will happen
is is it still New York Comic Con week
there's a bunch of trailers that are
dropping there's all kinds of bullseye
and daredevil so I'll try to get through
everything as fast as possible leave
your requests in the comments below
congratulations scientific your the
giveaway winner for my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details click here to watch Mark Ruffalo
try to spoil the title for Avengers 4
and click here for my non-spoilery venom
review thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]